the states that lost seats new york
pennsylvania michigan ohio west virginia
illinois and california
well done if republicans don't regain
the house in 2022 frankly you all should
lose your jobs
we now have census numbers and what the
census numbers show is that americans
are now
moving they are voting with their feet
they're moving from states like new york
like california
and they are going to places that are
more purple or red why well because it
is better to live in places that are
purple or red as a recent expatriate
from california
to florida let me tell you florida's
better it is way better and i'm not the
only one because florida
just picked up a congressional seat
thanks to the census bureau
texas picked up a couple of
congressional seats thanks to the census
bureau
by the way that was actually sort of an
underestimate
most people thought that florida was
going to pick up at least two not just
one
but the states that gained are almost
entirely purple or red and the states
that lost
are almost entirely blue the the sole
exception i believe there
is probably ohio which lost a
congressional seat and that is because
the rust belt has been moving
a lot into the sun belt according to the
washington post political power in the
united states will continue to shift
south of this decade as historically
democratic states that border the great
lakes give up congressional seats and
electoral votes to regions where
republicans currently enjoy a political
advantage
according to new data from the u.s
census bureau texas florida north
carolina you wonder why
your corporate media in new york and l.a
why they
despise texas and florida why they're
constantly ripping on texas in florida
it's because
all of the people who earn money in
these states and have the ability to
move
and don't have their heads so far up
their own rectums that's coming out
their head again
are moving away from new york and
connecticut and new jersey and
california
and they are moving instead to states
where they can actually live comfortable
nice free lives
texas florida and north carolina three
states that voted twice for president
trump
are set to gain and combine four
additional seats in congress in 2023
because of population growth granting
them collectively as many new votes in
the electoral college
for the next presidential election as
hawaii has in total so this does shift
some of the electoral college math
not only that it shifts the nature of
the house most political prognosticators
believe that republicans because of that
reapportionment
basically just gained three seats in the
house well democrats are only up by five
or six seats in the house right now
so that means the republicans are
already just thanks to the census bureau
on the verge of retaking the house of
representatives now that changes based
on redistricting in a lot of these
states
we know that in new york for example
there are a bunch of republican seats in
new york new york is going to redistrict
and they're attempting to to get rid of
a lot of those republican seats
but the same thing is presumably true in
republican states down south which again
are gaining population
four northern states with democratic
governors that president biden won in
2020 illinois michigan pennsylvania and
new york will each lose a single
congressional
seat ohio will lose one seat in congress
that's the only
actual red state that lost a seat so far
as i'm aware the data released monday
was better for the democrats than
expected
earlier census bureau estimates had
suggested congressional gains in florida
and texas would be even bigger
the margins in certain states that
determined the final congressional
council razor thin
new york lost a seat because of a
shortfall of only 89 people so thank you
to hero of the republic governor andrew
cuomo the greatest of all governors
it turns out that killing your own
population as well as
raising taxes making life basically
unlivable in your state led to
the loss of a congressional seat in your
state the release marked the start to a
constitutionally mandated effort to
redraw congressional districts across
the country
in advance of the 2022 election a
tangled litigious process likely to
benefit republican office holders
more than democratic ones next year
frankly if republicans don't regain the
house in 2022 given
joe biden's performance given the fact
that they are the out-of-power party
in an off-year election and given the
fact that republican states are gaining
seats
in the in the census bureau
reapportionment if they somehow fail
to regain the house in 2022 that is an
act of extraordinary incompetence
and this is not a secret i've told as
many republican legislators as i can
find and that's many of them since i
recently spoke at the at a republic a
house republican caucus
meeting i told them if you guys don't
retake the house in 2022 frankly you all
should lose your jobs
because this is a target rich
environment politically for you
joe biden is running up massive debt
massive deficits he's proposed 10
trillion dollars in spending this year
so far
okay so you guys you have a lot of room
to run here
all of this is a stark threat to
democratic control of the house which
will rest on a seven-vote margin with
four outstanding vacancies once newly
elected representative troy carter
democrat of louisiana takes
office in the coming weeks the results
show that the country grew over the past
decade by the second slowest rate in
history owing to an aging population
decreased fertility and slowing
immigration a slightly lower rate of
growth was recorded between 1930 and
so the the downturn thanks to covid
covet itself which killed off a lot of
people
the fact that people aren't having
babies particularly in urban centers
what this is leading to
is a is a slowing of growth in the
united states which actually is a
serious problem for a country that
continues to take on debt
that there will be no one alive to pay
right now the redistricting landscape is
of heavy advantage to republicans there
are many many states where republicans
control the state legislature
and redistricting is going to happen in
those states that includes places like
ohio west virginia north carolina
florida
and texas we're still not going to know
the partisan effect of the shift because
states have to sift through the
population data
it's going to be fun to hear from the
media how republican redistricting is
super racist and terrible but democratic
redistricting is wonderful and enjoyable
republican control of the redistricting
process in states like texas florida
north carolina according to the
washington post
is likely to increase the number of
congressional contests where republicans
have a chance of winning
republicans will control line drawing
for 187 congressional seats over the
coming year
democrats control 75 seats the remaining
seats that need to be drawn
will be decided by independent
commissions or divided governments
according to the cook
political report mike thumb battleground
director for the national republican
congressional committee said
redistricting favors republicans
it's not going to win back the majority
on its own but certainly it benefits
republicans
at this point all of which demonstrates
once again that when you govern your
states
like garbage people leave okay this is
the theme
the states that actually picked up in
total oregon one montana one colorado
one texas
two florida one in north carolina one
the states that lost seats new york
pennsylvania michigan ohio west virginia
illinois and california
that population shift is continuing the
midwest and the northeast are just
losing population
the south and the west are picking up
population except for california which
is losing population because it's
governed
like absolute garbage so well done
blue state governors you've done an
excellent job of driving people from
your states even though the media talk
about how wonderful you are it turns out
that
the people who live under you don't feel
the same way which is why so many people
have been leaving
and taking their vote and taking their
congressional seats and taking their
cash and moving to states that are not
seeking to destroy
their liberty again there's a great
hilarity to the fact that new york
lost to housing because it came up 89
people short on the census my favorite
part of that by the way is that members
of the new york delegation
were saying well you know if we just
kept recounting we'd certainly find 89
more people
weird because um i was informed that if
you did that with regard to votes
that was uh that was stealing the
election but if you do it with regard to
census bureau
then i guess that that's good just keep
recounting until you get exactly what
you want
never forget guys it's all about cynical
power grabs who's got two thumbs and
wants you
to like and subscribe